do we're told an agreement has been
reached in principle between Chelsea and
Benfica for the British record 105
million pound signing of Enzo Fernandez
now they've got what half an hour or so
to get the deal sheet in to try to sort
of at least indicate that they are ready
to complete this so real dramatic end to
this transfer window and a record for a
signing for a player many might not have
heard of just a month ago until he won
the World Cup with Argentina it's been a
rapid Ascent for the 21 year old and it
really does reflect Chelsea in this
modern era the fact is they had the new
ownership of Todd boldly replacing Roman
Abramovich in the last year but they've
kept up their spending they've spent 600
million pounds if this deal goes through
just in these two transfer Windows alone
this season half it coming in January
and we take a look at the numbers uh
that's the Premier League overall
spending in this January Toronto window
565 million pounds even without the
Fernandez deal now compared to the rest
of Europe the other four major leagues
combined in Germany Spain Italy and
France have only spent 190 million
pounds between them so one thing is
certain there is no cost to living
crisis in the Premier League although in
the next week or so we are expecting
action from the government on a
potential regulator for English football
and also to ensure how more of that
money flows throughout the English game
beyond the Top Flight Rob with an update
as the deadline approaches thank you
very much indeed